Resuelve para "x".
El valor absoluto de "2x" menos 5 es igual a 11.
¿Y qué quiere decir esto?
Bueno, primero vamos a pensar en el valor absoluto.
Si yo digo que un número en valor absoluto
es igual a 11 y déjame escribirlo aquí para
que te quede mucho más claro...
Si yo digo que el valor absoluto de "a" es igual a 11,
esto quiere decir que o "a" es 11...
vamos a ponerle aquí, o "a" es 11 en positivo
o su dado caso "a" puede ser también igual a -11,
porque recuerda que la función valor absoluto, lo que hace es, cuando tomas cantidades negativas,
las vas a pasar a positivas con
el mismo valor, es decir, multiplicas por
-1 lo que tengas adentro, eso cuando tenemos
una cantidad negativa.
Pues aquí vamos a hacer lo mismo, tenemos
algo adentro del valor absoluto igual a 11,
esto quiere decir que lo que está dentro
del valor absoluto o en su dado caso es 11
ó en el otro caso es igual a -11.
Así que déjame ponerlo aquí,
"2x" menos 5 es igual a 11  ó "2x" menos 5 es igual a -11,
exactamente lo mismo que escribí aquí
del lado derecho.
Vamos a escribirlo aquí abajo, ó "2x" menos 5 esto es igual a 11,  esta puede ser mi primera ecuación
o en su dado caso también tenemos otra solución,
ó "2x" menos 5 es igual a -11.
Y si te das cuenta, aquí ya tengo dos ecuaciones,
de las cuales puedo despejar a "x",
por lo tanto, vamos a despejar a "x" para encontrar
las soluciones de esta ecuación con valor absoluto.
Voy a sumar 5 de ambos lados de mi ecuación,
de esta primera ecuación.
¿Y que obtengo?
"2x" menos 5 es igual a 11, si sumo 5 de ambos
lados de la ecuación me queda aquí 16,
mientras que de este lado, -5 y 5 se van y me queda
simple y sencillamente "2x".
Y ahora, dividiendo todo entre 2, me queda
que "x" es igual a 16 entre 2, lo cual es 8.
Bueno, esta es la primera solución de
esta ecuación con valor absoluto,
ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo con
la segunda ecuación.
Tengo "2x" menos 5 es igual a -11, si sumo
5 de ambos lados de la ecuación me queda
que "2x" es igual a -11 más 5, lo cual me da -6.
Y ahora lo que voy a hacer es dividir ambas partes de la ecuación y me queda que 2 y 2 se van,
entonces del lado izquierdo me queda "x", mientras que del lado derecha me queda -6 entre 2, lo cual es -3.
Y bueno, ya tengo estas dos soluciones las cuales ambas son soluciones de esta ecuación
con valor absoluto y si ya que tenemos estas soluciones sería bastante bueno comprobarlo,
es decir, vamos a meterlas en esta ecuación, a ver si si cumple el valor absoluto.
Si yo digo que "x" vale 8,
¿qué me queda?
2 por 8 menos 5 esto en valor absoluto tiene
que tener que ser igual a 11.
Vamos a ver si sí.
2 por 8 es 16 menos 5 es 11,
entonces el valor absoluto de 11 es 11 y
sí se cumple, perfecto,
11 es igual a 11 y ya tenemos nuestra
primera comprobación.
Ahora vamos a ver si el valor de -3,
cumple esta ecuación.
2 por -3 = -5, todo esto en valor absoluto tiene que ser igual a 11. Y vamos a ver si sí.
2 por -3 es -6, -6 menos 5 en valor absoluto
tiene que ser igual a 11 positivo
y después -6  menos 5 es -11, el valor absoluto de -11 tiene que ser igual a 11 positivo
y ¿qué crees?
El valor absoluto de -11 es 11, 11 positivo,
es decir que 11 es igual a 11 y también cumple.
Así que nos vemos en el siguiente video.